you just got the necklace huh the real
diamond is it real diamonds you sure
actor SEC okay well then yeah legit guy
just gave yes he's a great man he's a
guy I just didn't want to have to blow
all that money on us but yeah that's
pretty good
I mean you're getting such praise for
this role I know you're a humble guy and
it probably feels a little weird sure
does
yeah no it's nice it's honestly movie I
love the movie I love those safty
brothers and when it gets praise from
other people I'm very happy for the boys
I'm happy for everybody
Howard where's the money right now what
do you think I'm done that means nothing
meant nothing please give me another
shot I knew it was good
it'sit'sit's when I saw it alone in the
room I as I do I love this thing so
that's that's the good news I know I
know it's a good movie GQ just named
your character the most stylish
character of the year I agree I'm
definitely if I wasn't the most I'd say
at least the top 20
you've seen the memes comparing you to
Billy Eilish they said Adam Sandler
walked or so Billy Eilish gonna love
Billy Eilish by the way absolutely my
kids my kids turned me on to Billy
Eilish like a year and a half ago and
then I saw her at Hollywood Bowl
wouldn't like it she's incredible I love
her
I saw an interview with her the other
morning my kids saw it and that she was
singing as a little kid and she's very
inspiring and just I love her stuff and
you are her Adam's sandler style like
well I I don't know if she knows that
but that's all right what was it like
for you to have all of these jewels in
the movie there was security on set and
everything right yes at the end of the
night I had you know $10,000 ring
$100,000 watch so the props would run
over to me at a trap in Galway let's go
ahead give me that you shot a lot of
scenes that no you don't usually do some
sexier stuff some fight scenes
yes I was filthy in this movie and yes
and I and it doesn't look great but it's
good movie
Julia told me she said well my
character's name was originally Sadie so
we changed that because it was weird
that's my daughter saying I say you
can't have my daughter's name in this
movie man what does the fam think of
seeing you in this role kind of a
transformation for you my wife can
handle it all my wife encouraged me to
do the movie my kids I said I don't want
them to see this until they're much much
maybe maybe 60 or 70 did you keep any
mementos from the set maybe steal a
little diamond or stole a lot of things
yes the block isn't as tight as they
think it is I put so many things in my
pocket every night fantastic last
questions for you idina menzel so
amazing but of course you get a sneak
peek at frozen - when idina menzel is
your sheet Amy - I would ask her
questions about the new one and she
would kind of just if she wouldn't
answer me but if the answer was yes she
would kind of stare at me like and I was
like oh that's a yes huh
so I knew a little bit of what was
coming with my kids - loved it saw it
opening night dressed dressed up my
little one dressed up as as Deena's
character and and I called the Dina so
the kids are there and they're loving it
and she was happy everyone in our office
was dreaming of a holiday collab between
a frozen song in the Hanukkah song yes
I'm glad I got that for all you guys
what want to see what my phone is says
right now Hebrew time that was for my
kid when she was sent in for her BOTS
myths when I was like Hebrew time baby
get it on I gotta get rid of that then
she had the Bat Mitzvah I didn't know
you were such a strict dad you're like I
got the let's get it on man at least 20
minutes Congrats on the movie by the way
Cole Sprouse your support knew you guys
stay close hey say it again well Sprouse
was here
Cole is he here can't wait to see him
you ever do the Big Daddy sequel I
wouldn't do that to him he's doing fine
he's doing fine
[Music]